and now you've written a book called
it's okay to be angry about capitalism
so why are you angry
I'm angry because in my country the
United States we have more income and
wealth inequality
than we've ever had in the history of
our country so the middle class
continues to shrink Working Class People
are struggling to put food on the table
but billionaires are doing phenomenally
well
and furthermore we have more
concentration of ownership in sector
after sector whether it's agriculture
media Wall Street Transportation fewer
and fewer large corporations control
what goes on in our country and on top
of that you got a billionaire class in
America that is able to contribute huge
amounts of money into individual
candidates and dominate the political
system so what we're looking at is a
nation which is rapidly becoming an
oligarchy you know we talk about Russia
and Putin's oligarchy well in the United
States we have an oligarchy as well
surely you can't be comparing Putin's
Russia we know we've seen firsthand
what's happening of course I'm not
talking about though that a small number
of people have much too much wealth much
too much economic and political power
that's what I'm talking about do you
think the Democratic president currently
um is really getting a grip on that I
think President Biden has done some very
important things I'm not sure he gets
the credit for that but I think in the
need to take on this oligarchy and to
demand that we have an economy not
different than here in the UK an economy
that works for all in not just the few
have we been doing enough no we have not
um you if you care about inequality
do we need to look at what we do as
consumers as well and if you care about
inequality is it okay to shop at Amazon
well I think that's a very good question
I'll let individuals make that answer
but what we should be doing absolutely
in the United States is being much more
vigorous in breaking up monopolies
Amazon is a monopoly not the only one
and what we've seen for many years is
these large corporations become much
larger and we don't have administrations
prepared to stop breaking them up
Biden's people are moving they're moving
a little bit too slowly they are moving
and the other thing I guess is wealth
taxes as well right are we taxing the
wealth in it well not in the States look
there are half a million people in the
United States who are homeless there are
85 million people uninsured or
undertured we don't have a National
Health Care system and you got
billionaires who have more money than
they can spend in a thousand lifetimes
how many homes do you need
how many islands do you need to own how
many jets do you need to own how many
Yachts do you need to own so I think we
should say enough is enough you are
successful in life you want to go out
you make money good become rich but
there should be a limit you don't need
10 billion dollars you don't need 50
billion dollars is it right that you've
been lobbying Biden to introduce higher
taxes on the super wealthy yes it is and
and what what answer well see what
happens I mean he's moving but not as
far as I would like to see okay now you
mentioned Healthcare and I know that's
one of the things you're pretty angry
about right here in the UK we're pretty
angry about Healthcare as well and if
you look at our system you know struggle
to get a GP appointment hundreds of
people dying every week because they
can't get ambulances on time you know
some people might be thinking this
system the NHS is fundamentally broken
maybe we should be looking at an
insurance model don't look at the United
States that's exactly the wrong
direction to look at
look at strengthening your own system
what this country did in 1948 was
revolutionary what you said at that
point in the formation of the NHS
Healthcare is a human right whether
you're rich you're poor you have a right
to go to a doctor and not take out your
wallet in the United States the function
of Health Care in America is not to
provide quality care to all it's to make
billions for the insurance companies so
strengthen the NR NHS you need more
money put money into it but don't go the
American route we're trying to get out
of that the labor party in the UK one of
the ways that they're looking at
potentially strengthening the NHS is
more Partnerships with the private
sector using capacity in the private
sector I would be nervous about that I
don't know all the details but it sounds
to me like the wrong direction really
you because of the private sector you
think is look the function of the
private sector is not to provide quality
care what the function of Health Care is
not complicated everybody should be
entitled to the best care the system can
provide
uh not to have a system in which
insurance companies make make huge
amounts of money
interesting another big debate here in
the UK is Wages as well and yeah we've
got double digit inflation wages not
keeping up people are going on strike
but the government is saying look if we
give you pay Rises that match inflation
that's just going to stay completion
even more what side of the debate are
you on well are they looking at
demanding as the wealthy to start paying
their fair share of taxes
you know that might be a better
alternative look working people in the
United States and in the UK are
struggling they're struggling with the
cost of housing cost of Education
everything else uh I think working
people nurses uh bus drivers I think
those people deserve decent wages they
need wages that can at least keep up
with inflation and in the states as well
I guess absolutely you think in the
United States we're also seeing a growth
in labor activity more and more workers
are standing up fighting back striking
uh and uh we're trying to workers are
also forming unions which is a very good
thing you know it's interesting talking
to you you're obviously brimming with
ideas you're obviously still pretty
angry about lots of stuff well I'm angry
in the sense that with all of the
technology out there I mean take a step
back and that's what this book is about
asking people to rethink things you
would think that with all of the
technology out there life would become
easier for people right if I give you a
tool that makes you more productive you
should perhaps be making more money or
working fewer hours does anyone really
think that's happening for Working
Families it is not and this issue is
going to get only worse with the
explosion of artificial intelligence and
Robotics we got to make sure that
technology works for workers not just
the owners of that technology I mean
with the ideas that you're putting
forward if Jay Biden doesn't run again
would you be tempted for another pill to
the presidency at this point we're
thinking that Biden is going to run
again okay not rolling it in or out
there very careful answer and what do
you what do you think I'm interested in
this why do you think in a difficult
time sometimes a really difficult you've
outlined some of the reasons why it's so
difficult for Working Families
people tend to in recent years
tapped the radical right not the radical
left well I think the demagogues all
over the world take the anger that
people feel people should be angry they
should be angry that they their kids in
many cases are doing worse than they are
going to be doing
they can't afford basic necessities of
life they are angry and what demagogues
say is don't look at the people who
really own the system don't look at the
ruling class don't look at the people
who cause the problems look at
immigrants look at people of color look
at gay people look at people it might be
different than you you're supposed to
hate them let's rally around those
hating those people rather than looking
at those who are really causing the
problems it's interesting isn't that I
mean we've seen it in in the UK in the
states as well the states as well of
course yeah certainly
um I guess um what others would say is
look you're coming from the radical left
we've seen what happens I don't think
it's all that radical do you not no
that's interesting
fighting for human rights for economic
rights is it radical to say that every
worker in America or the UK should earn
a living wage is it really radical to
say everybody's entitled to Quality
Health Care Quality education affordable
housing is it really radical to demand
that billionaires start paying their
share of taxes I don't think that's
radical I guess what others would say
though is like look if you want to make
a change you can't just sit from the
sidelines coming up with these ideas
that sound great you've got to win
elections
you haven't won an election in the
states Jeremy corbyn I have won a lot of
Elections I am a United States Senator
that's true for the presidency you're
right I stand corrected but you get
where I'm coming from you have to
compromise you have to win from the
center in order to no I don't accept
that in fact the way real change always
takes place is when millions of people
demand it and then suddenly you have
presidents or prime ministers to say I
think that that's a good idea because
they know that millions of people want
it at the end of the day what struggle
is about is working class people
standing up and demanding Justice and
the people on top will respond to that
do you think that perhaps politicians
from the center I guess some would say
more kind of compromising uh politicians
Joe Biden perhaps uh Kia stammer over
here in the UK they need to be a bit
more radical yes you do you'd like them
to read your book and to come up with a
few of those ideas take them on board
now you will forgive me there is one
constitutional issue in the UK that I'm
really interested genuinely to know what
your opinion is on it and that's
Scottish independence look it might be
something that you haven't given much
thought to but over here it's such a
live debate because of course we're
looking for a new leader of the Scottish
national party and one of the arguments
is that look Scotland tends to attack
more left politically they've obviously
had a conservative government in
Westminster for over a decade
what's your instinct on it what's your
guts say look I I I'm not an expert on
UK politics I very much appreciate what
the people of Scotland have done what
they're fighting for and my you know
initial thought not being an expert they
want to go their own way they should be
allowed to so you think they should at
least have the opportunity to to that
would seem to me
don't tell anybody I said that don't
worry that's just between us okay don't
worry it won't go anywhere
finally um because I know you're a busy
man you've you've done countless
interviews over the years including
about your book recently is there ever
you know a question you think I wish
someone had asked me that you think why
why is no one answered me this question
there are a lot of questions in fact one
of the whole chapters on the book is is
dealing with corporate control over the
media all right so in my country I don't
know what it is here it's different here
actually
we have eight major
media
corporate column conglomerates who
control about 90 percent of what the
American people see here in Reed so it's
not just a television network it's owned
by somebody else it's owned by somebody
else who control a lot of the media and
what ends up happening is it's not the
fake news that Trump talks about it's
not that report is lie they don't by and
large
what it is is there are areas that
people do not want to talk about for
example I have no one ever comes up to
me say Bernie what are you going to do
about the grotesque level of income and
wealth inequality nobody says Bernie why
are we spending twice as much on health
care as the people in the UK
and we've got 85 million people running
sugar in the church what's wrong with
our health care System
Bernie why is it that we are the only
major country on Earth in the United
States not to guarantee Paid Family and
Medical Leave
there are women in I understand you have
two children right I do all right in the
United States if you have there are
women today giving birth who will have
to go back to work in a week or two in
order to take care of the family they do
not get any paid family leave that is
pretty crazy to me all right so what we
are trying to do is build a movement to
address those inequalities and media
often just will not because they're
owned by very wealthy billionaires and
they don't want to stir things up so I
often don't get the questions that I
think need to be asked not just to me
but other elected officials okay thank
you very much indeed for your time thank
you thank you very much